ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to another exciting episode
of shimcast IRL I am filling in for Tim
who wrote us a letter saying he's having
a lot of fun at Camp before we dive into
tonight's stories I want to make two
really awesome announcements I think you
guys are going to be very excited to
hear both of these things the first
announcement is great not as good as the
second one but my YouTube channel and my
access to my YouTube channel and all of
my channels has been restored as of
earlier today so Freedom Tunes is back
thank you to the people at YouTube for
getting this cleared up thank you uh to
Tim for helping me get in touch
and also the second bit of good news I
want to share is that a little while ago
on the show I mentioned that there was a
young boy a little child at my church
who was born with skeletal dysplasia who
needed a very difficult and dangerous
surgery I asked you all for prayers he
has gotten the surgery he is good thank
you all so much for your prayers I
massively uh appreciate it in terms of
tonight's stories Marjorie Taylor green
shares explicit photos of Hunter Biden
in front of a house select committee and
also alleges that he has violated the
man act Jason Aldean's new music video
has been pulled for being supposedly
racist then again what doesn't the left
call racist and RFK proposes backing the
U.S dollar with Bitcoin and gold before
we get into all those things I want to
ask you all to smash the like button
please and thank you go to timcast.com
become a member if you become a member
you're going to get to watch the after
shows you're also going to be supporting
the Empire that we are building here to
try to bring truth to Media so I'm going
to ask all of you to do that but first
go over to casprood.com buy yourself
some cast Brew Coffee building culture
has never tasted so good we're very
excited to sponsor ourselves and offer
this product to all of you so if you
want to help us out you want to help us
with what we're doing pick up a bag and
tonight I am very excited to announce
that we are joined by presidential
candidate Vivek ramaswamy it's good to
be here man it's great to have you thank
you so much yeah glad to be here it's
it's uh I did this show I think a little
over a year ago and I had so much fun we
had to come back so here we are yeah you
had fun because I was in here man I'm
gonna drag all of it down that's good as
soon as Tim left he was like oh do we
have we can't get anyone better than
Sheamus but here I am so we're gonna
make the best of that's actually true
that's actually true he cried I forced
him out I said I'm the one who gets to
do this of course we also have our good
friend Hannah Claire hey I'm back I'm
Hannah clay brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm so glad to be here
tonight I think it's gonna be a great
conversation and of course we're here
with the the fitness Builder himself I'm
Ian crosland I gained another pound
today I'm doing protein shake right now
as we speak so I'll keep my mouth off
Vivek when you're president I want to
help you man I'll take it I'll work on
science I want to pull start pulling
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
turn it into graphene and Revitalize the
union make become a while fit yourself
yeah two bigger stronger faster man then
we'll make a movie let's do this yeah I
love the spirit let's go and I also have
Mr Dupree on the side what's happening
dog hey uh register when you are Sheamus
I'm surge.com excited to meet Vivek
pleasure I missed you last time for the
culture War so I'm glad I'm in town this
time uh yeah let's get rolling Sheamus
all right yeah so we have representative
Marjorie Taylor green holding up
explicit images of Hunter Biden during a
house oversight Committee hearing so the
hearing feature two IRS whistleblowers
who allege that the president's son
received special treatment during their
investigation into his business dealings
those of you who are regular Watchers of
the show will probably remember that we
talked about this story a few weeks ago
at least the story in reference to the
two IRS whistleblowers who were saying
Hunter was receiving special treatment
uh the investigation was being slow
walked and every effort was made to
ensure that it wasn't taken care of
effectively and competently Marjorie
Taylor green showed pictures that were
leaked from Hunter Biden's laptop she
also alleged that he purchased a ticket
and essentially brought this woman
across state lines which she argues
would be a violation of the man act
which is obviously a massive allegation
and green also alleged that the
president and Son used his business to
write off payments to prostitutes
illegally not a very good look
no especially not when you're the
president's son right I mean I think uh
James Palmer pointed this out that the
testimony that we heard today isn't
necessarily going to say anything we
didn't already know although I argue
that it's important to have an official
record of these things uh but rather
these two IRS agents were able to say or
testify to the fact that the doj did
intentionally slow walk their
investigation and treated Hunter the way
no one else would get to be treated we
make special exceptions for him well I
mean I think there are definitely two
standards of Justice in this country
right now amen this is not specific to
Biden and Trump alone I mean there's one
standard for Julian Assange who sits in
a foreign Prison still in Exile I'm
gonna try to see him later this year
another one for Chelsea Manning who is
the government agent who actually leaked
information to him because she's
transgender so now you see one standard
400 Biden a different one for somebody
who has a different last name be it
Trump or otherwise
part of the problem is we have this
bureaucracy the IRS is one example of it
but a bureaucracy that really
abandons the rule of law to decide what
it feels like doing on a given day and
so those two stories between what Marge
Taylor green saying about Hunter Biden
about the testimony of the two IRS
whistleblowers
these are deeply linked they're both
symptoms of a managerial class a
bureaucracy in this country that does
whatever it sees fit and is going to
effectively politically protect
whichever party is actually protecting
them and preserving them and their
existence and right now that's the
Democrat Party so they happen to be
protecting them if that change in the
future they'd protect whoever paid for
their continued existence but that's
exactly what's happening today yeah this
is absolutely nothing new I think some
people who are just waking up to these
things think that it's the first time
any of this has happened I mean this
goes back a very long time but just to
give a specific example 10 years ago I
believe a little longer ago than that we
knew that the IRS was targeting
conservative groups for audits under the
Obama Administration this is something
which has happened numerous times in the
past we also know that there were two
whistleblowers that actually spoke up
about this which I very much appreciate
here and that also lends credibility the
fact that you had two people at the IRS
stepping up and saying something fishy
is going on here so this wasn't one
individual person whose testimony might
have a little bit of a little bit less
credibility but what I'd like to ask you
is if you were elected president what
would you do to dismantle these
bureaucracies and what would you do to
ensure that there weren't two different
tracts within the justice system yes so
I think that a lot of Republicans end up
making a false promise without knowing
that they're making a false promise they
think it's a true promise they'll say
we're going to come in and reform the
bureaucracy yeah good luck it is
impossible yeah right because this is a
beast it's like a creation a monster
unto itself that existed long before we
arrived as somebody who ever got elected
and long after we're gone
and so I'm not going to make that false
promise to say that I can reform that
bureaucracy
but what the president can do is
actually shut it down and I think this
is where you know even Trump who's the
closest we ever got to at least
identifying this problem stop short
because the traditional wisdom is that
there are these things called Civil
Service protections which say that
members of the bureaucracy cannot be
fired
absent some
uh you know extreme finding of
misconduct
actually if you read the rules carefully
it doesn't work that way
the way it works is you can't fire
individuals right you can't have
backlash against you know any one
individual in that bureaucracy at one at
a time
but that's why what I'm bringing to
Washington DC is mass layoffs because
the Civil Service protections do not
apply on their own terms to mass layoffs
and mass layoffs is what we're bringing
to the federal government is I think it
takes somebody who's willing to break
the glass coming in from the outside
without inhibition and I think Trump
brought an element of that I'm
definitely bringing it
but you have to combine that with an
actual understanding of the law in the
Constitution and together that's what
it's going to take to shut this thing
down what concerns me about shutting it
down just like stopping it is getting a
Resurgence of like what they did with
the bath party in Iraq because they went
in there they conquered it and then they
fired them all and then they formed Isis
like these people have connections with
DARPA with Boeing like they are the
military and so like if we fired them
they just start their own secret
government I feel you know I think that
it's it's not a destination right I'm
not saying that we all have a party
there's one Silver Bullet solution and
then we're done
that's how we get to the start line
right we're not even at the start line
right now we're playing a different game
come in with some puppet claiming to be
the elected official sitting on top of
the managerial class that's a different
game I'm talking about how we get to the
start line of at least restoring
political power to the people who are
actually elected by the governed to
actually exercise it so that's the
starting point you're right it's like a
hydraulic pump or like a water balloon
you squeeze it in one place it'll pop up
somewhere else
but at least with acknowledging the
rules of the road being the people who
we elect to run the government are
actually the ones who want to run the
government yeah this managerial
bureaucracy they'll find their own
private sector version of that that
emerges or some quasi governmental
version that emerges even in the
agencies that exist yeah we need to Be
watchful of that but right now we're not
even playing the start line of that game
what would you replace it with
so so it depends on what the it is if
the it is the Department of Education
I'm not going to replace it with
anything amen if the it is the FBI I'm
going to shut it down and I'm not going
to replace it with anything a lot of
those functions are already being
performed by the U.S Marshals by the DEA
the drug enforcement agency and so you
go on down the list that's the reality
there are certain other functions like
you know that you you would say have to
continue to exist in some form say the
nuclear Regulatory Commission I said I
would shut that down because we haven't
had a nuclear power plant built in this
country in 35 some odd years because the
nuclear Regulatory Commission is
fundamentally hostile to it in that case
I think you can't reform the culture of
that agency you have to shut it down but
we'd rebuild from scratch an agency that
was actually committed to a rational
evaluation of the risks and benefits of
a given nuclear power plant so some
cases shut it down it stays shut down
certain cases you shut it down and then
rebuild something skeletal from scratch
to perform the basic function
and then certain other agencies you know
let's talk about the FDA let's talk
about the SEC let's talk about the U.S
federal reserve I'm talking about a 75
layoff of the people who already work
there and that I think will get the job
done how did we get here what made the
American people so willing to have such
an a bloated administrative State yeah
it was a sort of laziness in our culture
it actually started with laziness of the
elected officials right so
initially the way it was supposed to
work was the people who showed up in
Congress and in the U.S Senate they're
supposed to have the actual law making
Authority but also accountability
they started to get a little lazy with
that accountability these bills get into
the specifics of those details that's a
little too hard to deal with
presidents who we elected in the White
House started to similarly get lazy
saying that well you know the budgeting
process I'm supposed to ask Congress for
permission to spend money it's a little
too complicated let me delegate that
down
so it was sort of a dual delegation
the president of the United States
started to get a little lazy Congress
started to get a little lazy they said
let's just create this third-party
apparatus three letter agencies
where we don't actually have to be
accountable for the result because we
can blame it on them if things go badly
but if things go well we're still the
people who the public knows and I think
it they started attracting very
attention-hungry people to those roles
as well that's what created it is people
who wanted the glory without the
accountability yeah they shunted the
accountability to a third unspoken class
so the capital is a beautiful building
right but the U.S Department of
Education or the IRS or the FBI these
are drab government buildings nobody
visits that when they visit Washington
DC let's put the real accountability
over there but then the people who
actually said okay we're gonna assume
that position they're not the people who
actually needed the fame or the glory
they're the people who actually needed
the exercise of power and so in a
certain way everyone got what they
needed out of the trade right the people
who were running for elected office
today many of them just want to get on
cable news on a given night of the week
well the same principle applied to
actually the people who didn't
necessarily care about getting attention
but just actually wanted to exercise raw
power and so there was a division of
those who got attention that's what they
wanted versus those who got power
because that's what they wanted and that
studied in this new equilibrium of
having this administrative state that
said okay we'll exercise all the power
you guys just get to get to pretend like
you have it and get your dopamine hits
from getting on television or getting
your attention along the way that's a
long story short a big part of what
happened part of what I really
appreciate about that explanation is you
mentioned it just starting with a little
bit of laziness elected representatives
not wanting to do their job to the
fullest and most rigorous possible
extent and essentially abdicating by
trying to delegate to people it
shouldn't have been delicated to or
delegated to in the first place and so
part of what I try to stress and the
thing that I've talked about pretty
frequently on the show is that simply
slipping a device and having a people
who are not aspiring to something higher
in a spiritual and moral sense ends up
creating creating a tangle of problems
that you never would have anticipated
who would have thought at the time that
an elected leader just being a bit lazy
just not wanting to do what he had to do
that day could result in such a massive
and Bloated bureaucratic state to the
point where we ended up having an a duly
elected president being unseated or at
least having an attempt to unseat him
committed against him by the
administrative state
well I mean I think that there is
something deeper going on in our culture
it's probably the deeper explanation to
the question you asked as well
which is that we are all so starved
for purpose
and meaning yeah and identity right now
that you know if you don't bend the need
of the real thing you're going to bend
the need of something right so
you know a lot of us myself included
right get into this habit of complaining
about tyranny in the United States
getting about about the
abuse of governmental power but that
trick only works if you have a
population that quietly is hungering to
bend the need to something you don't
pledge allegiance to that flag you're
going to pledge allegiance to something
there's an old saying it goes if you
have a hole the size of God in your
heart and God does not fill it something
else will instead right the Israelites
are lost in the desert Book of Exodus
stuff here what do they what do they say
we want to go back and be ruled by the
Pharaoh yeah
Moses comes down from the Mountaintop
what do they do by the time he's come
back they've already got the golden calf
so
part of this is a culture that sort of
Demands obeisance and when we think
about freedom from the administrative
State or the autocracy of government
we owe ourselves a long hard look in the
mirror and ask ourselves how we achieve
freedom from our own impulse to bend the
knee because we are hungry for a higher
purpose that we're lacking I think
that's the deeper answer to your
question I I find it really interesting
I'm going to cut chains off yeah he's
signaling at me that he has a point but
it's my show now yeah oh are you kidding
me direct challenge we'll see about that
no what I think what you're saying is so
interesting in context of this uh
whistleblower testimony you know Joe
Ziegler came out and said you know I'm
I'm a gay man I'm a Democrat and I have
received threats I've been told I'm I'm
a traitor to the Democratic party
because I am disrupting the the order
and I'm creating division our country by
bringing forth this information and I
can't imagine what kind of pressure you
must feel especially because so many
people right and left but definitely a
lot of people on the left feel as though
their membership to the Democratic party
fills these voids it gives them a sense
of purpose and identity that really they
Crave You know I would say the left has
been masterful
at filling this void of identity and
purpose I I don't agree with the
prescription but
race gender sexuality climate
right these are the left's prescription
for that void
and I think where conservatives have
erred to be honest with you this is part
of what pulled me into this race
where conservatives have gone wrong is
that we've gotten complacent with saying
that
well we're going to criticize that
vision and point out all of the things
that are endlessly wrong with it there's
a lot there's a lot we could do I mean
my first book is about a lot of this my
second book is about a lot of this woke
Inc nation of victims here's what's
wrong with that vision of identity
grounded on your genetic attributes
but where we've fallen short is that
we haven't yet offered our own
alternative Vision yeah I think well I
think that's important I do before I had
a planet my man yeah before Hannah stole
my point there was something Annika
that's right you're getting called
Hannah from now on instead of Hannah so
aggressive here tonight we have a nice
guest she started it okay so there's one
thing there's a couple different things
I I want to say firstly your your last
response reminded me of uh three quotes
firstly a great quote from Chesterton
that when a man stops believing in God
it's not that he believes in nothing in
fact he often will believe in anything
and it's huge uh another quote is from
Augustine you were sort of mentioning
people looking at political tyranny and
not their own lives Augustine said a man
has as many Masters as he does vices and
we as a people have unlinked freedom and
virtue from each other as if Freedom has
nothing to do with your individual
capacity to choose to do good and is
merely the circumstance of having many
Alternatives and then the final
quote uh that it reminded me of was when
Soldier netskin said the the battle
between good and evil runs through the
heart of every man why just look at the
administrative State why just look at
the bureaucracy why just look at tyranny
when the evil exists inside of you as
well and you have to do the work to
become a more virtuous person if you
ever want to fight the the evil in the
system that said you made another Point
here about the left doing a very good
job of offering up this counter
narrative to people so they can fill
that void I I would argue it's even a
bit more malevolent than that and I
don't think it's necessarily intentional
on the part of all left-wing people who
are promoting this but all of the
structures that they've taken away from
us and tried to shame us for caring for
whether it's a sense of patriotism
whether it's a a faith in God and divine
revelation whether it is the cherishing
of your own family unit all of these
things are very important they're things
man needs but there are also things that
man has come to and understand of being
important through the exercise of virtue
all of these other things like sex or
race or even this strange kind of
reversion to a weird worship of the
weather and in signing intentionality to
climate events is really incredibly
primitive I think these are the things
that human beings just fall back into
when they don't have a rational way to
orient themselves towards the good I
actually think there's something
instinctual there and as we've torn away
the social conventions that have helped
us to behave more virtuously we're
falling back into things like group
Identity or seeing weather patterns as
an indication of immoral behavior that
that needs to be settled even through
things like population reduction which
is really another method of human
sacrifice and a somewhat abstracted
sense I actually actually there's a lot
to that because
in a certain sense the thing that
separates us from animals is our ability
to believe in something bigger than
ourselves
animals as best we know or non-human
animals don't have that same ability to
have faith yes and so the fact that
That's essential to our Humanity also
the flip side of that makes it something
that we really badly need to fulfill
yeah so long as we are actually fully
human beings
and if we're not going to fill it with
the real thing we're going to fill it
with something else and so my definition
of a cult is it's in many ways a
religion that has not withstood the test
of time
and I think that we have the rise of
these different secular cults
in America
that have oddly Arisen at the same time
in our National History yep right you
think it's a coincidence that we bow to
the god of climate as you said I like
the way you put it worshiping or
sort of sensing changes in weather and
patterns as something that we have to
use as an atonement for our sins it's an
interesting question
separate question of do you see that at
the same time that your identity is
based on your race your gender your
sexuality and that you're on some
intersectional pyramid higher or lower
based on the combination of those
attributes you inherit on the day you're
born or religion that says the sex of
the person you're attracted to is
hardwired on the day you're born at the
same time that you have to believe that
your own biological sex is not like
you're fluid over your life
I bring that up because what is a
faith-based system or a religious system
it's a system where you could espouse
otherwise illogical beliefs right logic
and reason could not lead you to these
beliefs but it has to be a different way
of believing them
that's what we as a human being have a
need for we have a need to have beliefs
that defy logic and so if it's not going
to be grounded in belief in a
traditional religion belief in God
even belief in a nation a commitment to
a nation is not something that flows out
of logic flows out of something that we
as human beings have a desire for of a
need for something bigger than ourselves
we're going to channel that impulse to
something else
but the problem and this is the danger
of it is not that it's not the
time-tested faiths
it's the fact that we then trick
ourselves into thinking that it isn't
Faith at all right because when you go
to church you know what you're doing
right you go to a temple you know what
you're doing you're praying to God
you're exercising a side of your brain
that's different than that which you're
exercising if you're pouring chemicals
in a lab and measuring things
but I think what's happened is in
absence of traditional faith and
traditional beliefs where we recognize
that we're exercising our faith to
believe in these things we see the rise
of new secular religions secular Cults
instead which we fail to recognize are
actually religious belief systems
exactly like the climate belief system
and I think the most dangerous religions
are the ones that we fail fail to
recognize
as religions in the first place and
delude ourselves into thinking that it's
actually logic or reason that led us
there exactly that's exactly what's
happening in the country today well
there's a few things I'd say in response
to that firstly ultimately I do agree
with the point that these ideological
systems are more or less religions but
rather than having a personal God they
have a much more abstract God and it
generally ends up boiling down to a form
of self-worship usually but I would push
back against one part of this I agree
that there are many religious systems
where the faith does conflict with
reason I don't believe faith has to
conflict with reason and I would say
part of what's so Insidious about this
kind of left-wing cult we're seeing in a
lot of these bizarre new ideas is it
directly does conflict with reason I
think there are elements within divine
revelation that a person could not have
reason to on their own but it doesn't
contradict reason or or it's not asking
you to accept something which is like
completely and totally absurd such as
your biological sex can change on a
daily basis it it gives you ideally the
tools and this isn't it's singular
purpose but it does give you the tools
if it's the the right system to interact
with the world in a way which is
actually productive and helpful in these
new kind of cultist beliefs don't so I
would definitely agree with you on that
second part yeah I think we actually
agree on the whole part because
the religious belief systems don't have
to conflict with reason of course they
don't
and so what I said is a cult is a
religious belief system that is not
withstood the test of time part of
withstanding the test of time is that I
think you do
you withstand the test of time better if
it is compatible with reason it's not
totally incompatible with reason the
problem with these near-term Cults right
the same cult we talked about the
biological sex being fluid versus sex is
the person you're attracted to being
fixed call that the cult of lgbtqia plus
the cult of climate effectively says
that
carbon emissions are bad if they come
from the United States but not if
they're coming from exactly you can't
believe those two things at the same
time and so it's the religions that
haven't withstood the test of time that
are the ones that actually run most
contrary to logic and reasons when it
comes to like climate science I don't
think it's unreasonable to think that
humans could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere we easily could nuclear war
is one way to do it we could do a lot of
ways comets could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere but what's unreasonable is to
tell people they have to stop producing
waste and that's the way to solve it
like people are gonna poop we're gonna
make waste we're gonna burn stuff to
stay warm so we need to figure out a way
not to stop I I believe it's
unreasonable to expect people to stop
producing the carbon dioxide and we have
to be reasonable about the climate we
need to reuse the waste this is why I'm
obsessed with pulling the carbon dioxide
out of the air it'll create another
climate crisis where we start to pull
too much carbon dioxide out of the air
and then we start to compete with the
trees and we need like a United Global
Coalition that's working together to not
pull too much methane and carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere because that is a
valuable resource yeah it's well it's an
interesting idea I think kind of
touching on this this concept of old
ideas and new ideas that uh Vivek was
mentioning I'm curious and where do you
sort of stand uh I I'll sort of launch
it in my perspective on this but I've
talked about it before so I'm curious
where you are on this when someone says
this is a new idea or that idea is old
and conservative and retrograde what's
your response to that well what's an
example what do you mean well often
people will try to label liberalism and
conservatism as a war between old ideas
and new ideas and conservatives just
like the old ideas and liberals like new
ideas
oh geez well I mean we stand on the
shoulders of giants nothing's new we
have new data we can see things from
different perspectives with microscopes
and telescopes and things like when you
get a radio telescope and you see the
cosmic microwave background radiation
for instance it's this web of radiation
left over from The Big Bang out in the
universe it looks like a neural net like
that is God to me that is a evidence
that there is a God in our universe and
I've been agnostic my entire life but
when you see that how can you deny that
that is not sentient or that or that it
is I mean it is it is
functionably active so that's like an
old idea that is now seen in a new way
it doesn't have to be liberal or
conservative it's like we're just human
seeing seeing things from different
perspectives and if you can I don't know
maybe if you can accept that some people
don't quite don't see it the way you see
it it'll be a lot easier to convince
them well the way you see it I think
that's an interesting point uh obviously
I I would disagree with some of the the
spiritual proposals that you're making
there about the nature of the universe
but what I will say is I think you hit
the nail on the head when you said
there's nothing new and I firmly believe
this there's nothing new Under the Sun
and Vivek you described a cult as a
religion that has not passed the test of
time I think that that is a very good
way of describing it and it's certainly
a helpful way of understanding it the
way I've always sort of conceptualized
the you know war between traditionalism
and progressivism is not that you have
you know old ideas trying to fight new
ideas it's that you have ideas that have
stood the test of time against ideas
that have been tried and have failed so
many miserably that people forgot about
them and now they're trying them again I
think it's very hubristic to say that
man has been thinking about such matters
for virtually all of human history and
now we've discovered something which is
totally unique and totally new I think
in terms of technological development
there are certain things we can discover
that are unique to our place and time
but when it comes to human moral
behavior these things are constants but
you know the problem and you mentioned
this too Vivek that the big problem
that's happening in the conservative
movement I see right now is that people
are screaming no at these things that
are rallying people in the liberal
whatever economic movement that are like
climate side whatever whatever and
rather than offer another idea it's just
no that's bad that's bad and that's
right it's not functional it's not that
inspiring and that doesn't move people
that doesn't move people towards
being the true version of themselves
they want to be which is what we all
hunger for and so you know what I said
left offers this narrative grounded in
race gender sexuality climate
well what I'm in this race doing
hopefully
is articulating a different Vision
grounded in the individual
the family
Nation
God Amen right so now you have a
different Vision we have competing
choices race gender sexuality climate
individual family Nation God at least
it's a different alternative Vision
which is what conservatism used to be
about it used to be about conserving
that's right those things right those
those pillars of human identity
why do we need those pillars of identity
you know the way I look at it is we are
in many ways like human beings the
analogy I would use we're like blind
bats
lost in a cave
trying to figure out where we are
how does a blind bat figure out where it
is sonar sonar echolocation right it
sends out signals so say we're in this
cave bounces off that wall it's
something that fixed it bounces back it
says this is where I am
let's I'm a human being I do the same
thing it bounce off that wall say my
family
the two parents mother and father who
brought me into this world that means
something to me that bounces back it
says this is where I am
sending out a signal it bounces off my
belief in God that is a true Faith to me
that balances back it tells me this is
where I am
of my belief in this nation that I'm a
citizen of this nation not some nebulous
Global citizen somewhere but that I'm a
citizen of this nation in our case the
United States of America that means
something to me that bounces back and
says this is where I am I work hard I
create something in the world you make
music that's great whatever it is
that is real it is true that bounces
back I'm proud of that it tells me this
is where I am
what happens when those things each
disappear
we send out these signals
and then nothing comes back
and that's when we're lost in that abyss
and so we will latch on to anything
race gender sexuality climate
and and the conservative movement isn't
a bit of a paradox here because we're
supposed to be conserving something but
when the thing we're supposed to be
conserving does not exist
now we have to be in the business of
actually recreating something or if it
was actually missing but the signal is
blocked or distorted because of
pharmaceuticals like 14 year olds on
Xanax or something crazy you can't
experience God properly if your mind is
tweaked by drugs I mean I don't think
you I don't think I don't think you can
have a healthy baby if you've got
amphetamines flushing through your
system like how can you even learn to
love if you hate if you're in pain from
from so not only is it if something is
missing but you need a clear mind what
do you think about colonizing Mars
this is not a topic we selected by the
way we're fine to talk about common
animals I'm in favor I'm in favor of
exploration I'm in favor of New
Frontiers
I do think that there's a it's so should
particularly the United States of
America lead the way in establishing
roots on Mars absolutely I'd like to see
that but I do think that it's an
interesting point I'm gonna tie to the
discussion we just had
there is a bit of escapism in that to
say that I'm going to find my sense of
meaning by going somewhere else when I
actually could have it right here at
home right yeah there isn't enough there
isn't anything we couldn't understand at
the atomic level that wouldn't be more
edifying and liberating for us that
would require us to go to Mars to do
instead I'm not denigrating the value of
going to Mars I would support it I think
as a spirit of human advancement and
human achievement and a down payment on
a future that's much longer than I
believe our past has been that's great
but I do
whatever the case may be I see one
serial substitute after another arising
saying that oh no maybe they think it's
going to give me fulfillment is going to
Mars yes it's that thing let's get
behind that
versus being grounded in the things that
have for most of our history grounded us
and given us meaning as human beings
get to know your neighbors yeah that
could be that all those things can be
that's like the individual the family
and the national absolutely take care of
yourself take care of the people around
you right I think that we'll hear a lot
more people worrying about taking care
of somebody in the Congo which I have no
problem with somebody in the United
States taking care of someone in the
Congo but what's your relationship with
your own family exactly your neighbors
right and I think that in the same way
there's an Impulse to say let me go to
Mars as a substitute for self-discovery
here at home I'm going to Mars to look
for something that I could have found by
just taking a long hard look in the
mirror myself which is actually a deeper
journey into the harder question of who
I really am and who we really are
and I think that's the hard work we
sometimes sidestep in terms of talking
about the climate or talking about
curing hunger on a continent halfway
around the world before we actually ask
ourselves who we really are and what
we're really doing here at home and I
think that characterizes the American
moment characterizes why much of the
modern left is lost
but it also characterizes the work cut
out ahead for conservatives or you don't
have to use the label conservatives but
leaders who want to fill that vacuum of
purpose and meaning in our country I
would totally agree with you uh and
piggybacking off of what you said here
about looking at home for problems that
you can solve this is something I
believe that Mother Teresa said when
someone asked her about traveling to
some other part of the world and helping
the poor she was she her response was
basically to say what about the
spiritual poverty that exists around you
what about helping to meet the spiritual
needs of the people in your own life who
are impoverished in that sense another
thing that you mentioned was caring a
lot about your country having some sense
of patriotism and a national identity
people having certain values that they
stand for as a result of their
citizenship in a nation as great as the
United States and how a lot of that has
been taken away from us recently there
was a song that was released by Jason
Aldean he he had this music video he put
out there it's really making the rounds
and there's been a lot of controversy
surrounding it and the song is called
try that in a small town and the whole
purpose of the song is basically to say
if you're behaving in the disrespectful
ways which are generally tolerated in
large cities in which we have been told
as a population for decades are morally
acceptable you're gonna have some
trouble in a small town so the lyrics
are cuss out a cop uh you know he's
describing doing things that are violent
or unacceptable and then he says try
that in a small town and see how far you
make it down the road we take care of
our own here you cross that line it
won't take long and you know find out or
for you to find out I recommend you
don't try that in a small town so this
is a music video where someone's
essentially saying don't come to our
town and cause problems I think it's a
great message there are people in the
media who have literally referred to
this as a pro lynching Anthem which is
the most bizarre insane in ridiculous
stretch of an interpretation I could
possibly uh imagine so this this idea
that traditionally American values are
racist that wanting to protect your
community and your town means that
you're in favor of lynching and that we
need to abandon our American values is
so pervasive that a song like this is
criticized whereas you have gangster rap
which talks about committing actual
crimes and harming innocent people and
treating women poorly and doing drugs in
the media never deprives that this it
looks like these lyrics could should
have been had the word if if you if you
cuss out a cop or spit in his face if
you stomp on the flag and light it up
you're gonna pay for it in a small town
like but the way it sounds stomp on the
flag you know cuss out a cop stomp on
the flag you're going to pay for it
doesn't it doesn't like have the
supposition uh so people might be
reading into it as if he's telling
people to do that I don't think that's
the problem Sarah said he's saying don't
do that because gangster rap tells
people to do horrible things like that
all the time and there's never a
controversy right I think part of the
problem is we live in a culture where uh
we're not expect supposed to expect our
neighbors to share values with us we're
supposed to Live and Let Live and he
used to love that phrase when I was
younger right because I was libertarian
ideals and it's not that they don't now
but I think ultimately the fabric of
society is strong when we have a
understanding of what is is acceptable
and what is not acceptable so the the
some of the stuff he's describing here
right like don't come to my town and
attack law enforcement and we can have
all kinds of debates about law
enforcement but we should all mutually
agree that we expect one another to
preserve our our safety right we don't
want that as a social contract to be
violated uh all of these ideas that he's
promoting are actually completely
reasonable it's just that he is
presenting them in a way that people
don't like and you're not supposed to
tell other people well you're not
supposed to do this this is against what
we're allowed to do we're supposed to
let people Live and Let Live however
they see fit which is just toxic
ultimately we function the best when we
are able to say I know that my neighbor
shares my values and therefore will not
look at me and say well I'm allowed to
do whatever I want and I'm going to yeah
so well I want to ask Vivek what how how
he he feels about this and what your
response to this song has been and also
just in general the the denigration of
American values and a national identity
and how it's brought us to this point
yeah so I think there's The Superficial
element of this which
you know frankly others have covered
over the course of today as well which
is something I agree with I said it this
morning
is that anytime you have a song that
actually celebrates who we really are
something that a majority of Americans
by the way at least until very recently
the values enshrined in that song would
have United all Americans
that's actually what is subject to
censorship and cancellation when in fact
songs that glorify violence or
other kinds of undesirable Behavior are
the ones that we actually end up
culturally venerating so there's a bit
of a paradox there
I do think there's something deeper
going on and it ties to our earlier
conversation in the country
which is this idea of whether we believe
in concentric circles of loyalty or not
right the song was about a small town
and and I think that we were having a
discussion earlier about
the community I mean how do you take
care of your own yourself or your family
before you're solving
Global poverty in Ethiopia or whether
you're addressing the climate
and I think that that's one of the
questions we have to regain alignment on
I think it's an interesting question I'm
offering one view I'm clearly biased to
that view
but I think that there's a legitimate
question of saying that no no we don't
necessarily have to solve problems at
home before we solve them solve them
somewhere else or do we actually take
care of the problems on our own Street
if you're try that in a small town it's
like almost I'm going to stand for my
people first I'm going to stand for my
family first I'm gonna stand for my town
first I'm gonna stand for my nation
first is that the right way to think
about our commitments or do we have
transcendental commitments that go
beyond those traditional boundaries
somewhere else and I think that's in
many ways it's not a right or left
question it's an interesting question
to ponder and I think that that's part
of what's going on when we make up these
new abstract religions to substitute for
the hard thing which is look in the
mirror and ask myself who I am actually
do something kind for my parents or for
my family members or my neighbors
in some ways Ukraine has actually become
a substitute for this right as a
substitute religion I mean if this song
was called try that in Ukraine I don't
think anyone would be complaining about
it exactly because what have we tried in
Ukraine or Russia you know on one hand
last year the thing that we said cluster
bombs that were going to be war crimes
or now the very things that we will send
over to Ukraine and so it just becomes a
the re-emergence of a new kind of
religion I'm gonna have a new one every
couple years I mean a couple years ago
we were all posting black squares and
you know there's always a symbol there's
always something and it's a test right
do you comply can I give you an outward
symbol that I line up the way that uh
dominant culture wants me to and I think
that's why songs like this are so
interesting is because they make people
so I mean variety has this article
saying that it's the most cynical song
when really it's a call to action and
actual protection this is the I mean
like look if you want to argue there's
something wrong with the song I think
you're incorrect but this is the most
cynical song of all the songs on air
today of all the songs on the radio this
is the most cynical you're out of your
mind it seems like a psychological I
don't want to be too like conspiracy but
it seems like a psychological operation
with the internet now we've got all the
nations of Earth influencing our nation
we're all influencing each other of
course but they're like overt
applications to corrupt and disband the
United States because it's the global
leader and who's who's making who's
who's seeding this this that that's a
bad thing to protect your neighbors
who's who's doing that is it the Chinese
I don't want to be crazy conspiracy
because I don't know but like who wants
the U.S follow the money I don't know
but I I get a vibe that this is not a
natural phenomenon from within our
country the reaction to this you is
which yeah yeah you know it's it's
plausible to me it's almost so bizarre
that that is a very fair question to ask
in some ways China is absolutely
responsible for a lot of this right
because China you know the game they
have played I'm gonna come back and say
that's not the entire explanation but I
think there's a lot of truth to it
though because China has played this
game on our culture for the last 20 some
odd years which is they want our psychic
insecurities to flourish they want us to
be psychologically insecure and here's
how they do it right the spread of
global capitalism in the 1990s was
actually their way of accomplishing this
where we fell into this trap that said
we were going to export Big Macs and
happy meals and western music was a big
part of this too to places like China to
spread democracy that was our vision of
democratic capitalism in the 1990s
bipartisan consensus by the way
Republicans and Democrats alike
what they realized is oh wait a minute
we can use these vehicles as a way to
actually spread our values back to them
we they thought they could use our money
to get them to be more like us China
says okay we're going to use access to
our Market to get America to be more
like us how did that work
what they basically said is you can't
enter the Chinese market be it a music
company a movie company Etc a lot of
entertainment fits this description you
can't enter Disney if it's this
description the NBA fits this
description you can't enter the Chinese
market
unless and until
you abide by the ccp's way of doing
things but we will roll out the red
carpet if you criticize the United
States yeah so this idea of
self-loathing of large companies
institutions entertainment institutions
in particular
relentlessly criticizing the United
States
while actually staying silent about the
actual human rights atrocities in places
like China that started in some ways as
a form of a psyop right by China on the
United States to say we're going to get
those institutions that you guys
venerate over there many of them are
companies or entertainment providers to
relentlessly criticize the us because
the more you do that while also staying
quiet and criticism on China the more
they're going to roll out the red carpet
for those companies and institutions to
be able to expand into the Chinese
market which means more money yeah so it
certainly there was a psyop component to
this but that trick only works
if we have a culture
that's still willing to buy up what
they're selling which goes back to that
earlier
absence of purpose and meaning and
identity in our culture yeah I think
you're absolutely right about the fact
that the the Chinese government has a
much better grasp on what is going to
tug at the heartstrings in what will
upset the sensibilities of the American
people as opposed to the American
people's understanding of what is going
to upset people in other nations or in
our own or in our own that's a very fair
point uh so one
one story I usually bring about the uh
Biden Administration with respect to how
effective I think he's been as a leader
on the foreign stage is he told this
story in and again this is him telling
this story he thought this made him look
good the story was he met with Vladimir
Putin and he said to Vladimir Putin I
don't think you have a soul man
and according to him Vladimir Putin
responded we understand each other okay
I hear this story and I go the president
of the United States just told a foreign
leader who was waging a war that he
thinks he's mean this is not going to
upset that foreign leader if this ever
even happened on the other hand what
does China do China tells the United
States of America that the United States
of America is racist and needs to
apologize for being racist despite the
fact that in order to Market a film in
China you have to reduce the size of
black characters on the poster China
doesn't care about racism but they know
that the United States has a high
prefixation on it so they try to
manipulate us with it and you touched
earlier uh turn our psychic insecurities
against us as Weapons back against us
and then they use capitalism as a
vehicle to enforce it exactly because
companies don't get to play ball in
China unless they actually carry out
that dictate it's just the game it's how
they play it and this is actually why
I've loved talking about the nine Dash
slide in relation to the Barbie movie I
think so many people are not aware of
the subtle games that China plays so
having this line on a map that probably
a lot of us students are used to seeing
there but as soon as someone in Vietnam
says hey by the way that's actually a
claim to land that belongs to us a bunch
of Americans only have to go oh wait
I've never ever thought about anything
that affects you because I take the
information that has provided to me
without question and they have no
culture I mean there's a lot of reasons
why someone in America may not be aware
of the Territorial map of the South
China Sea on the other hand how
interesting that the Barbie movie is
suddenly this thing that calls attention
to the subtle uh claim from China to
this historical area yeah it's
fascinating you use the example of a
movie Top Gun the recent release of Top
Gun had a lot of those attributes to it
too
where I don't know if you guys noticed
but the
enemy was some nebulous vague Other
Nation we don't know who it is with snow
it yeah yeah and by the way
the old Top Gun the Maverick jacket that
had the Taiwan and the Japanese flag on
it
in the revised cut of the movie that had
disappeared in the original cut you know
it was actually real in the original
movie was actually original version yeah
there was actually identified animation
we're talking about the US and USSR an
actual rival here at some nebulous
Nation why is that
China's first read was that this movie
was too patriotic for the US to be
played in China so they come back and
make those concessions so part of that
that's that's micro that's at the at the
margin right well the Japan flag and the
Taiwan flag no longer show up it's a
nebulous alternative enemy arrival as
though it was disconnected with the
present reality in the United States
made it slightly less patriotic than it
otherwise was
is it any surprise that you then see the
same types of reactions from the same
movie industry associations or recording
industry associations that then are
engaged in self-flogging here in the
United States even as they will expand
into the Chinese market without a peep
so I do think that there is a cynical
Force at work here Ian I think you're
totally right about that
but I don't think it's the whole
explanation right that just amplifies
a deeper insecurity that still existed
in the first place yeah I think a lot of
the security comes from uh drug abuse
from the pharmaceutical industry we've
been broken by the opiate crisis in the
90s into whatever's going on now with
fentanyl I mean I've been through drug
abuse I know and it wasn't hard drugs it
was weed for the most part but and I've
been through alcohol some alcohol abuse
it was I was a shell of a human being I
had to find I started mines because I
didn't know I was asked to be a part of
it thank God and I found purpose and I'm
beginning to claw my way back to be
being able to love myself again but
these kids that are on the drugs there's
kids on amphetamines like I agree with
you that that destroyed shaken humans
are very susceptible to psychological
operations yeah how do you propose that
we disentangle Sheamus I'm sorry do you
want you have a question you want to ask
right now uh no no I would actually like
to hear an answer to the question you
asked how do we disentangle from China
without a while maintaining our
alliances with them while still
maintaining friendly relations so I
think that in the next instance of that
that's going to be very difficult to do
but what friendly relations do we need
to maintain some of the other ones we've
cut off
so if I'm US president I'm thinking
January 2025 I'm taking office here's
how it's going to look all right I think
we have to actually re-enter some of the
deals we exited trade deals we exited
with places like Japan South Korea
Australia India Vietnam you go straight
around the Pacific Rim I think we have
to re-enter that to say that I'm now in
a position to sit across the table from
Xi Jinping and say we're cutting the
cord there was one though the
trans-pacific partnership I'm not sure
if the TPP yeah the um the investors
State dispute settlement Clause within
that allows Malaysian oil companies to
sue American citizens if they decide
which I think is messed up so what I
would say is I'm a big fan of using
Silver Linings in our favor so that was
the TPP now we have the revised
cptpp they want the usn right so I would
use the fact that Trump pulled out as
leverage to say hey we're coming back
but here are the concessions we need
from Malaysia to Japan subsidizing their
state-owned Enterprises there's some
tweaks we'll need there but believe me
now that we're not in it we have the
leverage to say we're coming back in on
these terms we come back in but those
are largely still with friendly Nations
yeah that then puts me in a position as
the president to sit across the table
from Xi Jinping and he'll know I mean it
when I say
we're cutting the cord we're declaring
total Independence we're Banning U.S
businesses from doing business in China
you will not buy land in our country if
you're affiliated with the CCP you won't
donate to universities in our country
we're decoupling
unless you either radically reform and
play by the same rules no IP theft no
data theft but also no turning companies
into your one-sided cultural and
political lobbying ponds in the United
States
and if you don't meet our conditions
then we're out yeah I actually think Xi
Jinping that meets our demands that's I
think what happens yeah um and I I think
that's a very good point there's
something you mentioned there a little
bit earlier about like global capitalism
and how this neoliberal Vision has
resulted in us allowing ourselves to be
susceptible to the economic leverage of
hostile Nations there was this idea that
was very popular that I became
familiarized with heavily in my
libertarian phase known as the golden
arches Theory basically this idea that
two nations with a McDonald's had never
gone to war with one another Well
surprise surprise Russia and Ukraine
both have McDonald's their uh in
operation now on this question of
countries that we are allied with um
decoupling or just tension growing with
Nations that were were hostile to it
seems as if we're seeing something
similar in the U.S just with respect to
our own states which is a kind of a
segue here into a story about another
bus of migrants which was carried from
Texas to Los Angeles so this is
something we've seen in the news
repeatedly uh in this instance the the
bus left Brownsville Texas on Monday at
4 25 local time and arrived at Union
Station at 6 30. it had 45 Asylum
Seekers from various countries including
Brazil Chile China Colombia Guatemala
Haiti Honduras and Venezuela according
to the Coalition for Humane inter Humane
immigrant rights I apologize uh it
mentions here in the article that the
bus included 37 adults and eight
children with the largest group of
migrants 23 people hailing from
Venezuela so it seems to me as if people
who are in states that are more wealthy
and further from the border do don't
have as much of a problem with
unfettered migration and of course
people in Border towns who are actually
directly affected by it do have an issue
with it now what we often hear from
left-wing activists on this issue is
there's simply a failure of empathy on
the part of people who believe the
federal government should have any
oversight over who's crossing the border
or that border patrol should be able to
do its job in securing our border of
course the irony is they're totally
incapable of being compassionate towards
people who live in border states and
actually have to wrestle with the
struggles of unfettered migration you
know look it's actually an area for
National Unity that I see here
so I ended up visiting uh now a couple
months ago now I visited the south side
of Chicago
now at eight which part I went to South
Shore okay went to other parts of South
Chicago oh really originally yeah yeah
so South Shore High School right now is
being converted into an encampment for
myself actually
by the way seven thousand dollars per
person per month is roughly what that
costs well it's like 90 000 a year but
yeah I mean that's exactly if you were
if you were making 90k a year and
spending all of it uh each month without
saving anything that's and not paying
your taxes like that's how much it is
untaxed right because these are illegal
migrants by definition and so people in
that town and by the way this is
far left supposedly far left territory
hard Democratic stronghold not a place
where Republican politicians go
frankly not even a place for many
Democrat politicians go
who were probably more strongly in favor
of closing the Border then even many
traditional Republican donors who I meet
with on a given basis
and that's interesting to me because
that's
that's an America First principle right
it doesn't fit in the Democratic
Republican boundaries but they're asking
a legitimate question which goes back to
that earlier conversation we were having
why are we taking care of somebody else
first instead of starting right here
at home yep and so their question was
look I had trouble getting baby formula
or sneakers you've got sneakers and baby
formula for people who are showing up
illegally into this country breaking the
law they're getting seven thousand
dollar checks what am I getting
which I think is not an unreasonable
question to ask and so anyway this issue
around border security
I think there is far more consensus in
this country across traditional
boundaries then the media would have you
believe traditional media would have you
believe certainly
I think that most Americans who I've met
support the idea that I've advanced
which is that building the wall isn't
enough I mean look you want to talk
about how fentanyl gets into this
country there's cartel financed tunnels
underneath those walls now much of what
people think they're buying is Percocet
or wheat or whatever is often even laced
now with fentanyl
but the way we solve that problem and
the migrant crisis along with it is use
our military to secure that southern
border we're now using our military
equipment and resources to secure
somebody else's border Halfway Around
the World
let's use our own military to secure our
own Southern border I think we do it for
our northern border too
that's how you address the actual crisis
and I think that there's broad consensus
around that because just walk down the
list do you believe that Nations should
have borders
that's certainly my belief but there are
certain people who say we shouldn't have
Borders or whatever okay fine let's
smoke that out and get that on the table
but that's a tiny Fringe minority of
people most people in this country say
they want borders but then if you want
borders then okay if you believe in a
border then have a border yep and if we
can't use our own military to secure our
own border that means we don't believe
in the existence of the importance of
that board in the first place which is
why I said I would close that Loop yeah
absolutely would you end Birthright
citizenship I see Birth by citizenship
as a danger to the people who being
trapped across the border right this
promise that if you are born in America
you get to stay means that you're going
to be uh willing to take huge risks to
get here which we know are incredibly
dangerous to everyone involved yeah so I
would end Birthright citizenship for
illegal immigrants the children of
illegal immigrants well what does it
mean for everybody else I mean we're all
citizens whether sixth generation or
first generation in my case if you're
born in this country you have
citizenship if you're born under legal
circumstances but I think that if
somebody comes to this country illegally
and has a child while here I do think we
have to end Birthright citizenship but
does that mean you Deport like a
one-year-old I think you you do the
family you take the whole family unit so
so I'm strongly opposed to policies that
would separate kids from their parents
I think that that was discussed even in
in the Trump Administration and
otherwise as a tactic for deterring
people from coming
as a pro-family leader I will not adopt
such a policy but we will send back the
family unit as such and I think that if
you came to this country illegally the
right answer is you have to be sent back
to your country of origin come back
through the same legal means getting in
the same line that everybody who's
coming into this country legally is
already pursuing I would tend to agree
with that and what a lot of people will
say is deportation is so cruel it's so
horrible when it happens all right yeah
I would agree it's not the optimal
solution or circumstance that's why we
have to have strong border security to
ensure people do not come here illegally
so that we don't have to deport people
if you're against deportation you should
be in favor of having very strong
borders the crazy thing about borders
and walls is they are not that's not
where you defend the Romans knew that
that's why the Romans invaded their
neighbors because you had to create a
perimeter of defense and I don't want to
see I don't want a war with Mexico but
if they're going to allow an invasion
it's like what other choice have they
left us with
so I I think there's a couple things
that I would make as hard line policies
here
end any form of foreign aid to Mexico or
Central America until the Border crisis
is dealt with period yeah right I think
that they have not yet borne the
consequences of actually a border crisis
that actually many of those illegal
migrants crossing over aren't even
originating in Mexico they're
originating countries the majority are
not the majority of people that
overwhelm the Border are not the
overwhelming majority right and so
Mexico doesn't face any of that
accountability they're still a recipient
of that foreign aid and so I think we
have to use economic levels in this case
just turning off foreign aid on less
than until they've solved that problem
over there I would end Sanctuary cities
and funding for Sanctuary cities driving
the demand side of this here in the
United States I would use our military
to literally station undeployed troops
we don't need to find a war somewhere
else on the other other side of the
world station them along our own
Southern border this is if we intended
to solve that problem and as president I
do this is how we actually end that
migrant crisis the fentanyl crisis talk
about the human trafficking crisis in
this country that's how we do it would
you cap sorry would you cap legal
immigration do you have any uh any
feeling on restrictions for legal
immigration I think there should be
restrictions the restrictions are not a
specific number that we want to finish
eyes the Restriction is twofold both are
merit-based restrictions
are you going to make a contribution to
this country and then crucially there's
a second element to this too for me
do you actually know something about
this country and demonstrate a desire to
be a part of it and so this was where
the the question of Birthright
citizenship goes deeper for me
is I don't think citizenship should be
something that anybody automatically
takes for granted born here or not
I think every 18 year old should have to
pass the same Civics test that an
immigrant has to pass in order to become
a naturalized citizen in this country I
love that I I think you got to know
something about the country if you want
to actually call yourself a citizen of
that Nation I think that ought to be
true if you're an immigrant I'd pull up
that Civics test not just from the
citizenship side I'd pull up a version
of that to the front end to even get
into this country it selects for people
who have taken the time to learn
something about the country who have
demonstrated themselves to want to be
part of the country and then yes to work
hard and be an industrious member of our
society contributing to our country and
so I think that should be the limit but
I think that the idea of using a number
then we're just playing tug of war
argument numbers that misses the point
this is the way we have to filter for
the kind of people who should and should
not be able to enter this country and
then just because you're born here
doesn't mean that the act of just being
born ta-da you're born and it happened
to have arbitrarily been in the United
States of America you know there's
something beautiful about Birthright
citizenship in the American experiment
which is to say that your citizenship in
this country is not based on your
ethnicity
or your allegiance to a monarch or even
your religion
that it's anybody who's born here can be
a citizen I would take that to the next
level to say it's not just about being
born here but anybody who truly makes
contributions to this country and
pledges allegiance to this country and
knows something about the country
they're the ones who actually are the
true Capital citizens and that's I mean
many people find that view radical maybe
it is it's not I don't think that's
radical at all
the radicals bad yeah well this is
something I've heard you say in the past
that you would you would have people who
were over the age of 18 take a Civics
test before they're able to vote and
then once they get to 25 they can vote
in general but you would restrict voting
between those uh or between that that
age Gap I actually happen to think that
that's a good idea I don't know that I'm
saying I would specifically endorse that
exact policy or how I would flesh out
but when I hear it it sounds right to me
because historically in this country the
voting age was 21 years old and this was
at a time when you were expected to be
on your own taking care of yourself at
the age of 16. so by the time you got to
voting age you you knew a thing or two
about the world You'd Survive down your
own you'd paid your rent so to speak you
knew what life was like for other people
I remember when I was in high school I
graduated 10 years ago I hadn't turned
18 by the time the election happened but
I remember a friend of mine went out and
he voted for Obama why because he didn't
know anything about Obama he didn't
really listen to any of his speeches but
well I think he's the guy who wants to
legalize weed so I'm voting for him I'm
sorry 18 year olds are not in a position
where they know enough about the world
where they're qualified to vote and if
they are in that position they are a
minority and we should have a kind of
test to vet for those people I think
that's perfectly legit it's the exact
same test I'm not making up some new
tests from scratch it's the exact same
test we've decided
that an immigrant has to pass in order
to become a voting citizen of this
country I'll give you examples of what
they ask in the test I mean how many
branches of government are there what
are they what branch of government does
the U.S president lead
is it so objectionable to save your
voting for U.S president that you know
what branch of government the U.S
president actually leads I think it is
not no and so so
the implementation of this proposal it's
been a little while since I talked about
it and it wasn't
I think people will believe me when I
say this I was not doing this to score
political points this did not pull
particularly well as an idea my job is
to persuade people yeah that this is
what we need to revive in our country so
right now I'll remind you something that
a lot of people forget
we have a Selective Service requirement
in the U.S that's right men between the
age of 18 and 25 have to on pain of
criminal penalty that means potentially
going to jail register for Selective
Service that's the draft we don't have
an active draft but if you don't
register between the age of 18 to 25
you're doing so at behest of criminal
penalties
I would decriminalize that
I don't think that should be the way we
do things here
but in replacement of that I said you're
free you're not going to jail whether or
not you register for Selective Service
but if you want the ultimate Civic
privilege in this country of voting
before the age of 25 then pass the darn
Civics test and if tests aren't for you
then serve the country for six months
either in the military or in a first
responder role and I think that is an
absolutely fair thing to ask but it's
also and I'm going to make a prediction
on this
voting rates in this country amongst
young people which are already really
low
will Skyrocket
Skyrocket after you actually make the
act of voting mean something yeah it's
been a long time since we've done that I
completely agree with you and one thing
that I find particularly suspicious
about the Democratic establishment today
is that so many of their efforts are
catered towards people they know are
going to be uninformed voters so for
example you see these get out and vote
commercials on television we're a
celebrity tells you that you should go
select a certain candidate and they
won't necessarily tell you to vote for
the Democrat but the question is if a
person wasn't going to vote until Will
Ferrell told them to is this really
someone we want voting in our elections
and I think the answer to that question
is genuinely no if you're only going to
vote because a celebrity told you to you
probably don't know or care enough to be
in the voting booth so we're constantly
hearing about the civic duty to vote
well what about the civic duty to be
informed I think that exists as well and
I think it's a really good idea to have
a test that tries to select for people
on the basis of how much they actually
know about the system yeah and I think
studies bear out that when people are
bought into something when they have to
govern it and protect it they have to
participate through uh civil
participation they have to take a test
to show that they are part of the system
they are more likely to feel the the
sense of Duty and that's so important
we've talked earlier about sort of
reinvigorating our culture to feel a
sense of patriotism to feel a sense of
purpose and this is one of the ways we
do it we have to Institute I mean
obviously this isn't a micro change but
we have to Institute these changes that
ultimately direct the young people in
America towards a more purpose-filled
life I got just to clarify are you
saying that in order to vote at the age
of it you'd either take a test or join
The Selective Service I I say that if
you want to vote between the ages of 18
and 25 you either have to pass the same
Civics test that every immigrant has to
pass in order to become a voting citizen
of this country
or else serve for six months either in a
military or first responder role okay
because there's like a I don't want to
call them an underclass but there's
people with low nutrition that the
parents have been very poor race the
descendants of slaves for instance that
didn't have access to money wealth
education and nutrition and the IQ I
mean it that can affect IQ you know not
having good nutrition we should fix that
but here's one here's one the standards
I believe in consistency so there's
actually a particular schedule of
exceptions even for immigrants who come
to this country to be naturalized
citizens so you know there are mental
handicaps or otherwise that stop someone
from being able to take a test so I
would apply that same framework I'm a
big fan of not Reinventing Wheels when
they don't need to be reinvented we've
already had a process it's one that's
active in place today to say that if
you're an immigrant to the country even
if you've paid taxes for 10 years or
whatever
there's a process required to go through
being a voting citizen of this country
for 99.9 of people it means taking that
test and passing it are there 0.1
exceptions you know handicapped of
various kinds of course there are follow
the same rubric that you do for
immigrants but my point is at the age of
18 you shouldn't just passively age into
citizenship just like someone who comes
to this country doesn't passively get to
enjoy the Privileges of citizenship and
I want to use that to just raise a
deeper point I haven't brought this up
before in conversations about this but
like I like this format we're actually
having a real conversation and this is
not like a two-minute TV yeah checking
off boxes are awful you know I mean
there's a time and place for everything
so so you know he likes us better take
that mainstream media yeah you hear that
Donald just kidding I love you I think
this is good this is good this is this
is I think this is the direction of
where we're gonna have to go if we're
Reviving The Country to actually have
open and unfiltered this conversation
what you should do as president is have
these things daily or I will do I will
continue participating podcast from the
Oval Office here we go yeah why not
right I would like we should have open
with with everyday citizens
who are it's like somebody's randomly
selected which it's like the old
fireside chat right it's the modern
version bring that back but the point I
was going to make was this about
citizenship
right such an interesting concept to
ponder and what does it mean to be a
citizen
the way we think about it today
I think it's a it's a feature of the
modern moment we live in
we're taught to think about it in terms
of what do I get
right what do I get if I'm a citizen
it's something that I go get what do I
enjoy
what does that give me
I'm going to challenge that
it's gonna it may be a little bit
uncomfortable but it should be more
familiar than strange
what does it actually mean to be a
citizen for most of our history for much
of our history women couldn't vote right
so you may say being a citizen means you
vote oh you get this thing I get this
thing I have to vote
well for much of our history you know
let's is usually the case of women women
couldn't vote but they were still
citizens
maybe there's something else going on
here with respect to citizenship
that isn't entirely about
or even mostly about what I get
maybe just maybe think about it for a
second try it on you know what I say to
people who might disagree with me
and I try to do practice what I preach
too is you get a new idea try it on like
a set of clothes
see if it fits if it doesn't fit you can
put it back on the rack full refund
policy okay but just try it on like a
set of clothes for a second
maybe citizenship is actually about
obligation
um I like that a lot maybe citizenship
is actually about Duty maybe that's
actually what the whole thing is about
in the first place is to say that you
know what I live in a free society that
allows me people like me
a kid of parents who came to this
country as immigrants with no money in
their pocket who goes on to found
multi-billion dollar companies at the
age of 37 and self-finance a
presidential run by putting tens of
millions of dollars of my own
hard-earned money too that's the
American dream that's what I get that's
what I got to live but maybe citizenship
is about something else
yeah citizenship's about
Duty I mean that's the Reagan quote
right that's not what you what your
country yeah okay sorry yeah mix up All
My Presidents
what you can do for your country and
there is a sense there is a lack of Duty
I think there is a culture that demands
that it be given and it be allowed to
take but it does not give back and I so
I completely agree with everything that
you just said there there's a conception
of rights which was was I would say
um much more common historically than it
is today but it it's basically the idea
that rights are a product of Duties and
not vice versa so today our
understanding is basically as follows
well you have rights and you just have
them you can't explain how or why maybe
we'll we'll reference God maybe you know
if we don't believe in God but we do
believe in rights it's like the
invisible morality particles uh that
float around us I have no clue but we
just have these rights and then when you
exercise your rights sometimes you incur
responsibilities I believe it is the
exact opposite there are things you are
made to do as a person and because you
are made to do these things you have an
obligation to do them for example a man
has an obligation to care for his family
because he has an obligation to care for
his family financially and provide for
them that means he has a right to seek
outlicit methods of providing for them
uninterfered with or a person has a duty
to protect themselves if you have a duty
to protect yourselves then you have a
right to the best possible tool
necessary for protecting yourself which
is why we have something like the Second
Amendment but I find that almost
everyone in politics gets this entirely
backwards they say you have the right
and then the duty but the truth is no
you have the right because you have a
deal yes and that is that's so in a
simple framework that's what I'm saying
is at the age of 18 you think about okay
I have an obligation to at least serve
or at least to know something about the
country and then I have an equal voice
and vote in determining that direction
but that policy like you know I've
gotten into a lot of discussions and
last few months about it
it's almost
obsessing over the detail with false
Precision about one idea that's part of
a broader world view that I bring to the
idea of citizenship in this country
itself yeah I think we need to revive
that idea of civic duty and we've
fallen into the Trap of thinking that
American identity is all about
individualism right that it's just about
me me me
and I don't apologize by the way for
free market capitalism huh I'm an
Unapologetic embracer of free market
capitalism the best known system to man
to lift people up from poverty
but I just don't think that's the whole
story I think there's a separate and
important equally co-equal story
that we're also part of a Nation that's
bigger than the sum of its parts that we
as Citizens not as capitalists but as
Citizens
oh a duty
to that Nation right so 1776 was the
year of the birth of the nation that was
the year of The Wealth of Nations
that was Adam Smith's famous text it was
also the year of the Declaration of
Independence and I think that
both of these
are America's parents
and the only the five point I wanted to
put on this this actually relates to our
earlier discussion about religion
is that you hear a lot in this country
people invoke this term the
judeo-christian values that this nation
was founded on it this nation was
founded on judeo-christian values
but nobody ever stops to talk about what
are those values that's exactly right is
it one of those values
it's fundamental to this conversation is
the idea of Duty to have it to discharge
Duty it involves making a sacrifice amen
again God asked
Abraham to sacrifice his son Isaac he
didn't have to follow through with it it
turned out yeah but he was willing to
make that sacrifice and then in the New
Testament what God
sacrifices his son
for the people yeah Christ gives himself
up willingly
and that idea is woven into the idea of
citizenship itself is that there's a
certain sacrifice required to be a
citizen that's an example of a
judeo-christian value woven into not a
direct democracy but a constitutional
republic which involves those Civic
duties absolutely I couldn't agree with
you more and you have mentioned
capitalism here a few times you've also
mentioned spirituality and I think
something very Insidious has happened
here with a decoupling of markets from
an understanding of what man is the fact
that man is is not merely matter he is
matter and spirit and he has spiritual
needs
capitalism stripped of any reference to
the supernatural to our creator to
spirituality and communism both suffer
from a massive flaw which is that they
essentially promote the idea that if we
just rearrange matter properly we will
unlock Utopia the physical world is just
a combination lock and if we can arrange
things in the exact right manner we're
going to unlock the Gates of Heaven and
everyone will be happy for the rest of
History we'll reach this kind of
hegelian uh pseudo eschatonical end to
everything and of course that's complete
nonsense if you ignore what man is and
you only focus on production and moving
forward raw economic forces without
reference to what is good for man you
end up in an a horribly unbearably
spiritually impoverished environment
environment and often a very materially
poor environment as well because when
people don't cultivate those virtues as
a turns out they don't even end up
retaining their ability to produce as
well you talked about judeo-christian
values I was thinking about the second
commandment Thou shalt have no other
fault no false idols and yet we have
money money the obsession with this
false idol of money and so these
International Banks the bank for
international settlements the federal
reserves of Bank of England bank of
Australia they've they've they're waving
us around with like a carrot like you
want a loan you want to play our game
ESG you want to be part of this false
idol like they're dangling the false
idol there so I've heard you talk about
read redirecting our our investments
away from indexes that play the the
BlackRock game and into some sort of I
don't know what you call it a national
index or something that is like uh that
values not Christian values but just
values like not even American values man
values that incur Freedom like Natural
american-born Freedom what do you how
would you do that yeah so let me let me
actually this is such an interesting
topic here so the let's just pick up
from Adam Smith's first book was
actually about ethics the second book
was actually about and
his view is there has to be a moral
Society for capitalism to be able to
work its magic on yes right and I
believe the same thing by the way I
think that capitalism is the best system
known to organize the society's Affairs
if
our it's the perfect system if our wants
actually match our needs
and the difference the little daylight
between our wants and our needs might be
a crude definition of this thing we call
virtue
okay so I think I think capitalism
against the backdrop of a virtuous
Society for organizing stuff you know
things tangible material Goods it's a
perfect system for organizing the
distribution of goods against the
backdrop of a virtuous Society where our
wants match our needs but modern social
media otherwise has called that bluff
that our wants the modern pharmaceutical
market drug Market or wants don't always
match our actual true needs as human
beings
so then this is actually what temptingly
led to the birth of a movement that I
strongly disagree with but
a movement that had an answer to that
question nonetheless that was what gave
birth to the rise of stakeholder
capitalism right
I say this as someone who's a Critic
probably this the
most unsparing critic of stakeholder
capitalism in America in the last four
years but I say this to give the best
shake to The View
is it says that capitalism was made for
moral people and so we need to reinfuse
the morality into capitalism itself to
say that when we're allocating dollars
we're taking environmental or social
factors into account not just the
fetishization of green pieces of paper
that there's more to the story I'm
giving us charitable of and you know
true
truly empathetic account as I can
I have a different world view of how to
deal with it right my view is let the
green pieces of paper be the green
pieces of paper
right that's okay
if it's just about stuff
but there's a separate sphere of our
lives in our body politic in the Civic
sphere of Our Lives or the spiritual
sphere of Our Lives
where that money ought to have no
influence whatsoever that's right right
and so I'm one of these people who
resists the idea of infusing those moral
judgments into how the dollars are
allocated but instead to make sure the
allocation of dollars in that sport of
capitalism is just one of many spheres
maybe even one of many small spheres
of a total life well lived in a society
well-functioning
and so part of my objection to
stakeholder capitalism is that it
wrongfully marries our body politic with
our system of allocating goods and
services and stuff
when in fact I don't think we need
capitalism and democracy to share the
same bed what I think we actually need
is a clean divorce and both of those are
part of what it mean to be American so
anyway to your question what was
happening with these index funds
BlackRock and State Street and Vanguard
what they said is not only are we going
to use your money to buy stocks in the
overall stock market but we're also
going to use your money to vote for
certain environmental and social agendas
that it turns out many people most
people in this country do not agree with
racial Equity audits we could go down
the list quota systems on boards
and that's co-mingling a social agenda
into capitalism where you're supposed to
your investment dollars are supposed to
go to the best investments they could
find and vote for the best policies they
can to maximize profit so actually what
I started was a separate way of creating
index funds a company called strive that
said the same Investments but with a
different philosophy of voting focusing
on Excellence over political agendas
uh would Define Excellence yeah so this
is this is an important question
so at the individual level I think
Excellence or meritocracy
refers to any system in which
you are free to realize your maximal
potential without anybody standing in
your way whatever your god-given
potential is
maybe it's on the basketball court maybe
it's
as a musician maybe it's in the
classroom or as a in mathematics that
you're able to achieve your maximal
potential that's what Excellence means
at the individual level at the level of
a company
I think it means that you have a mission
a worthy mission
and that your job is to exclusively
excel at that mission that doesn't mean
that there aren't other worthy missions
for other companies or institutions to
pursue
but let another company or another
institution pursue it but your company
your job is to achieve your mission and
yes unapologetically create value for
the people who back you in the process
if their mission is to you know stop
climate change like these vague or weird
like racist missions do you still
support the Excellence of those
so those are very unlikely
to survive in a system of capitalism
because the way capitalism works is you
have to provide something of tangible
value to someone that exceeds the cost
of what it takes for you to provide it
to them so somebody's free to do that
right and if they were able to provide
something of value in the process then I
have no problem with that being the
mission so wearing my hat of being let's
say when I was back when I was running
strive my hat was I'm not going to pass
judgment on your mission maybe it's to
be the world's most successful
restaurant chain that delivers delic you
know delicious food to people and brings
them to light maybe your mission is to
go to Mars
whatever it is if it's a worthy Mission
and you stick to your mission
great that's how you actually maximize
long run value for shareholders but my
problem is you say your mission is to
develop medicines to save people's lives
or to develop notebooks that people can
capture their thoughts in
and yet you're also claiming to solve
climate change and racial Injustice at
the same time
that is something other than what I
would call the pursuit of corporate
Excellence
um when you are looking for corporate
Excellence like a bigger return than
you're what you're putting into it
what's the time scale because a lot of
people argue well we're just going to
put money in at a loss for 20 or 40
years until you see that the world is
now better because there's less carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere is it a year
one year so I think each investor has to
Define for themselves what their time
Horizon is but I believe that we're
talking over long-term time Horizons now
this long-termism argument has become
a cover a smoke screen for effectively
advancing agendas that had nothing to do
with Excellence or value creation but in
the guise of saying but 500 years from
now when we and our kids and our
grandkids are dead and gone it will have
created value that becomes mythology
that becomes a new religion in its own
right so I reject the Jujitsu and the
falsehood of that but in principle I'm
talking about long-run value creation
can I ask a question why do you think
it's trendy among I'm gonna say young
progressives but maybe a lot of people
to say that you know capitalism is bad
why is there so much uh antipathy
towards capitalism yeah I could give you
a uh
a somewhat cynical and somewhat
historical account here okay I'm excited
so so start with an old quote from have
you heard of have any of you heard of uh
Ludwig von mises yeah yeah okay got it
got it you know not everyone not
everyone has it we're a weird room as he
is called the the Mack Daddy of like
communicating Austrian Theory yeah yeah
he he he had Hayek or the mack Daddy's I
would say yeah so
here I I would I'm not going to get this
exactly right but I'll get you off the
top of my head at least approximately
right
he said there's two ways for the son of
a great man and you know man woman girl
doesn't matter whatever I like the
picture
very inclusive the point stands
regardless but I'm talking to you so the
son of a great man
can exceed his father in one of two ways
one of them is to exceed his father on
his own terms which by definition in the
thought experiment of a great man is
hard to do
the second is to exceed his father not
on his own terms
but on subjective terms of moral
superiority
and that was a lot easier because that
morality is subjectively defined
why'd I bring up this random quote from
Von mises I'm trying to explain why it's
trendy to say that we hate capitals yes
so we are now our dads basically yeah
you got it we are now in the middle of
the largest intergenerational wealth
transfer in human history from Baby
Boomers to Millennials and gen Z that's
what's happening right now
so there's two ways to exceed your
father one is on his own terms that's
really hard because he's already said a
hard bar High bar and that's hard work
but the other is
maybe let's just call the whole game
immoral and we're going to exceed him on
morally Superior terms
that's a big part of I think what's
going on is a sort of
psychic apologism as a substitute for
achievement
now that's a cynical account I think
there's some real factors too and I got
my first job in the fall of 2007.
at a hedge fund in New York City on the
eve of the 2008 financial crisis rough
time right I mean I ended up getting you
know things worked out for me but a lot
of my peers who entered the workforce at
the same time are jaded and cynical
saying that hey it was supposed to be
that if you worked hard and you did your
part that you could get ahead through
your own dedication well that's not the
way it worked out and the guys who got
bailed out weren't the guys who did any
of that at all so I do think that
there's a jaded
generation that has good reason I was
told that I get a four-year college
degree I take on all this debt I'm going
to get that job enter the workforce pay
that back through my own hard work but
then there's this 2008 financial crisis
oh and the guys who get bailed out are
the guys who actually made tens of
millions of dollars of their drivers
drive them home from the 85 Broad Street
downtown to Goldman Sachs or whatever it
is musing about how terrible the
financial system is while they go to
their penthouse on the Upper East Side
in their car service well I'm still just
joined without with college debt no
money in the bank being told that if I
work hard and I just got laid off so I
think that there's a there's a version
of this that the Seer timing of when
many millennials
I'm 37 right people my age entered the
workforce they were given good reasons
to be jaded because they were promised
and told one thing about the American
dream and what they actually lived was
another and so that's the charitable and
sympathetic account the cynical account
is well we're still into hating your
prior generation of baby boomers that
you're not going to stack up to so you
might as well claim to be more morally
Superior to them I think it's a little
bit of both going on
my own philosophy and I'm Not tooting my
own horn here I'm just saying this in
the small hope that this gives
some inspiration to people who may be
able to live the same dream that I have
hardship is not a choice in life
right hardship is something that happens
to you my parents actually encountered
plenty of it as we were growing up my
dad faced
you know I think a ruthless round of
layoffs at geu under Jack Welch's tenure
when my dad was you know 10 steps down
the totem pole in their org chart
but what did he do he went to night
school at law school for four years I
was in sixth grade I used to go with him
and sit with him in the back of the
classroom because we didn't have child
care or anything else full day at work
45-minute drive Northern Kentucky but he
kept his job that way because they had a
shortage of patent attorneys
I say this because I grew up in a
household where that was the example
that was set for me so when I entered
the workforce yeah 2008 financial crisis
hit six months into my job we had some
problems
but but I remember the example my
parents said hardship
is something that happens to you it's
not something you choose
but victimhood is a choice
yeah we choose to be victims you don't
choose your hardship but you do choose
victimhood you can choose not to be a
victim and hardship is not the same
thing as victimhood
and I share that because there are
legitimate grievances that many
Millennials and gen Z members growing up
in our American economy can have
honestly for most of human history most
people of any skin color or whatever we
all have some grievance we can latch on
to
but I think a big part of where we
landed in this case of self-loathing was
this deeper psychic
insecurity that we're actually afraid
of trying to realize our full potential
because if we fail we're afraid of that
failure we're afraid to match up to the
standard set by the great man or baby
boomer generation that came before us
and a long answer to question but but no
it's great it's a really good the idea
of choice is really important I I think
you know I'm also a first generation
American and I think about that
regularly when you have the choice to be
here when you have the choice to be in
America and to uh live your life this
way and to raise your family here so I
think I think that's such a good theme
to uh to close on where'd your parents
come from uh Canada and England so it's
English speaking for sure but definitely
there are cultural differences and I
think growing up without Family Support
it's just a whole uh mindset that they
you chose to be here and I remember this
idea of young celebrities saying well if
Trump wins then I will move to Canada
and being like you have no idea what you
were born into you guys are so
privileged you can't see it and I don't
use that word lately I got one final
question we're gonna go super chats
pretty soon is it is this been like two
hours already dude yeah so it's an hour
and 30 yeah yes already yeah yeah this
time yeah it's been great yeah dude it's
been great having you in and again so
are we even in a system of capitalism
with fractional Reserve banking in March
2020 infinite Reserve currency like is
that even capitalism it's not
so that's a good question you're asking
the right questions
it is a hollowed-out husk of this thing
we call capitalism is it capitalism
we're engaging in global free trade with
a mercantilist actor in the form of the
Chinese Communist party that has
non-financial political demands as a
condition for expanding and doing
business there is it capitalism for
Airbnb to hand over the user data of
American users as a condition for
expanding in the Chinese market it's not
but let me answer your question is it
capitalism when you have the Federal
Reserve Printing and reigning money from
on high like Mana from Heaven it's like
you're is it really skiing if you're
skiing on artificial snow yeah well
you're not skiing anymore if they turn
off the snow machine which is what's
happened now with Titan monetary policy
so as a side note and I think I'm the
only certainly on the Republican side
the only presidential candidate talking
about this
I think we have to restore dollar
stability as the sole Mandate of the U.S
federal reserve cut the playing God game
managing inflation and unemployment
trying to hit two Targets with one Arrow
disastrously missing both cut that game
out we're done with it and to say that
we're restoring a single Mandate of
stabilizing the US dollar you mentioned
this earlier you know narcotics of a
different storyline
stabilize the dollar as a unit of
measurement against Commodities yes a
gold nickel silver Bitcoin so I I think
the Bitcoin for me for a number of
reasons does not yet meet that commodity
basket I'm a Bitcoin fan I spoke of the
Bitcoin conference I just want to
stabilize the dollar against Agriculture
and farm Commodities gold silver nickel
and there could be a top point in time
where Bitcoin becomes part of that
commodity basket there's some technical
reasons why I wouldn't include that
today
but the main point is stabilize the
dollar as a unit of measurement rather
than trying to actually play Financial
God from on high yeah I massively
appreciate that you made this uh analogy
about it like raining down like Mana
from Heaven I guess the only caveat is
if the Mana was just like less filling
the more of it rained out it's really
more like splitting the Mana into
smaller thesis yeah yeah the way I like
to think of it is it's almost like we're
running this casino and then we're going
people aren't spending enough money at
the casino we'll make more chips it's
like ah no that's not it's interesting
so in the fall of ancient Rome right
there's some deep parallels to what we
see in the United States today so
septimius Severus uh well it's a fun
story about September servers he's
weirdly an emperor that now in temporary
modern contemporary Western history
we've somehow decided to celebrate
because HBO or I can't remember which
network it was created the series
calling him the black Emperor uh he
apparently had darker skin than his than
the other Roman emperors and so anyway
we remember him really well and they've
made the series that's the first
black man to walk on England
soil was came not as a slave but as a
conqueror and so they've glorified him
but actually it turns out he was a
disastrous Emperor as a side note the
Romans didn't see him as a black Emperor
they just saw him as a guy who had
slightly darker skin just like you know
we have different shades of eye color
today that's the way they looked at
people who had different skin colors
they were all Romans as Citizens by the
way to tie up her earlier conversation
but anyway this guy he was a terrible
Emperor one of the reasons he was
terrible he just kept diluting the value
of silver in the Denarius but he would
just go on spending sprees for money
they didn't have and it was like 1 60th
and then it was like 1 600th of the
amount of silver was left in the
Denarius
but back at his in his day the way they
would do it replenish it was the black
Emperor would go to Northern Africa and
just plunder a bunch of silver you know
rape a pillage and then come back
we don't do things that way anymore and
so in a certain sense
the parallels between the end of the
Roman Empire or you know one of the
minions of the so-called ends of the
Roman Empire and where we are today are
somewhat striking but we don't even
Avail ourselves of the same
tactics that septimius Severus or others
would have used in the ending days of
the Roman Empire today so this is
timeless principles is my point it's not
specific to America it's Timeless across
Nations well uh in the spirit of getting
more silver let's move on over to Super
chats we have that was a good transition
that was a really good
transitions are incredible they're all
really good and the audience loves them
and they're ranting and raving about
them back away Chris how does this work
so we just take questions yeah yes let
me take some questions if you want to
chime in with it you can so if you don't
want to you don't have to it's just
whatever is is interesting to you and we
usually just kind of go around uh
Christina H says Sheamus please tell
Hannah Claire that she was pronouncing
Nevada wrong last night thank you
sincerely a lifelong Nevada I don't know
how she's pronouncing it but it's Nevada
I'm saying Nevada
you like being wrong about things and
that's totally acceptable if you get
coached on how to say that state's name
how would you pronounce
there's there's my favorite restaurant
in the country is in Nevada
it's called Bertha mirandas in Reno and
it is the best Mexican food I've ever
had and that's all I'll say about Nevada
wow uh uh Raymond g and it is Nevada not
Nevada uh Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Vivek thank you for coming if you win
the presidency would you pardon Sheamus
if the truth was that he did in fact
steal Tim spoon so just so you know
there's been an ugly lie going around a
smear that I stole spoons from Tim Poole
there's no evidence that this ever
occurred you guys know me you know I
wouldn't do something like that I'm not
that kind of guy but this person's
question I think was more to cast doubt
on my repeated denials of this crime I
guess the question is would you pardon
me if I had done this
yeah I gotta get to the truth of the
matter man I I I was about to say I
trusted you you're making eye contact oh
my goodness but then you started looking
straight into the camera
but I wouldn't do that I wouldn't I'm
not that kind of person how do you know
that I I don't know I don't know if I
know that the vague I wouldn't do it how
do you see how a trial Bears out I'm
telling you we gotta count all the
spoons and make a decision after that I
kind of feel like Mercy is upon us we're
at a time of like forgiveness how do you
feel about Mass pardons I'm talking
about Hillary Clinton's emails Joe
Biden's son Donald Trump just let the
past go move so so you're asking a deep
question uh
moving we're getting back into serious
mode because I love that you just Break
Stuff where we're going live you just
get like real serious real fast so this
is this is important
I take a lot of inspiration from Nelson
Mandela okay Nelson Mandela was a guy
who brought together a nation who was
far more divided than ours is today
and one of the things I mean I've been
very vocal about this in this
presidential campaign I've said that I
would pardon Donald Trump if I'm elected
president I do not want to see my
competition eliminated I want to win
this election by convincing the voters
of this country that I'm best positioned
to take the America First agenda forward
not by having the federal administrative
State eliminate my competition
I think there will come a time when once
we have spoken the truth and I don't
think we're there yet I think there are
truths that yet still need to be exposed
where I would be willing
to say that we go around the table 360
Degrees we acknowledge the truth we will
not lie we'll not sweep it under a rug
but we will lay down arms
and say we are moving forward
as one nation and I know a lot of people
aren't going to be thrilled about me
saying that right because I think we're
in a mood a national mood right now to
say that no no our goal we are at War
internally in the country and we want to
Pummel the other side of the ground
using the same means that they've been
exploiting in the other direction and I
understand that and I am all in for
exposing exactly how deep that rot runs
but there will come a time in this
country
where it will take a leader
to say that we're done with that phase
of our recent past we're done with that
chapter of our national life we're done
with the weaponization ping pong
right now it's ping before it goes to
the other side of palm
let's say we're done playing that game
and so
in my journey
take office of January 2025.
I'll be leading a nation and not a
political party
and that is an idea that I
am very open to after we've gotten to
the truth of the matter of all of the
ways in which the government has
actually lied to us yeah good answer
um T-Rex Pet Shop says Vivek your
comments on Trump's indictment were
based we should not allow political
persecution is your motivation to
destroy three-letter agencies true stop
supporting woke pet stores like PetSmart
Petco and Chewie were we are an
anti-wilk alternative now I don't think
they're accusing you of supporting those
books at stores just to be clear uh I
think they're promoting their own brand
but they're allowed to do yeah of course
that is that is that is what the United
States is all about but uh yeah so did
you have an answer to that um I I think
you kind of addressed a lot of that
during the show yeah I mean I I
I am fundamentally
anti-government but a limited government
that we the people cause to come into
existence that's the bargain of its
existence and my my problem today is
that we tell ourselves we live in a
three branch constitutional republic
when in fact the political power is
exercised by that fourth branch of
government so actually I'm flying
literally minutes after that we're done
here to New Hampshire where tomorrow I
will be delivering a speech laying out
exactly how
I will shut down the administrative
State on strong constitutional and legal
Authority and I'd like to boast and brag
and whatever but I'm just going to State
something that I think is true I don't
believe in false humility either
I think I'm the single presidential
candidate who has run in this country in
either party in the last 30 years who
has the best understanding of how to
actually shut down that fourth Branch
shut down the Deep State shut down those
three letter agencies and that's what
I'm going to be talking about in a
pretty extensive speech in New Hampshire
tomorrow night
um we have oh I'm so sorry here
um from Alberto chippries
um or chiprest I'm sorry uh I'm still
I'm still excuse me carrying up in
episodes or I think they meant to say
catching up yeah I'm still catching up
in episodes from last week and couldn't
believe how surprised the crew was at
the thought of vivec running as VP
um I'm still learning about him but I
see him as Trump's VP running mate well
I don't think you're running to be VP
but I'll let you speak for yourself here
yeah so I'm not I'm not running to be
anything other than Vivek president so
maybe that's the VP they were talking
I'm just kidding
how long did you rehearse that joke not
at all I just came to mind actually as
he when he was saying VP it was like all
right there we go so so uh the truth is
not an ego thing I just don't do well in
a number two position right
and I think we've all got out each look
ourselves in the mirror and ask
ourselves how are we going to make a
maximal contribution to this country
believe me there are meaningful ways big
maybe even more meaningful ways of
impacting this country than doing it
through politics including even through
the presidency
I've written three books in the last two
years I've built businesses I built
strive to compete against BlackRock I've
built other companies in the past
employed thousands of people in this
country there's many ways of driving
change in this country and there are
actually a lot of other talented
politicians in the Republican party that
you know I think has a deeper bench than
it gets credit for one of those people
should take all of the cabinet slots if
it's not me
I think in one of my unique gifts is the
ability to be a successful Builder an
executive and leader
and I can't do that from a position
where I'm reporting into somebody else I
don't think Donald Trump would be
particularly effective in a cabinet
position either I think certain people
are just wired and cut out to do things
in a certain way
and so when I think about how do I want
to use my talents best to advance the
interests of this nation
the conclusion I came to is I think I'm
best positioned to reach the next
Generation to deliver national pride to
as an outsider but also somebody who
understands the Constitution shut down
that deep State administrative state in
a way that Trump didn't quite get to I
know how to do these things I think it's
going to take an outsider to do it I'm
independent financially I don't have to
pay any heed to a donor class I've put
you know 15 million dollars plus already
of my hard-earned money and we're going
to stop at nothing to stay independent
but we're not doing that too too
go through the motions are you starting
to think about who you would want in a
vice president like what are you looking
for yeah so there's a couple different
models actually I'm actually thinking a
lot well first we nailed the federal
judges which I released this last week
that's really important
now actually thinking more about cabinet
level positions and then also who I'm
going to put in positions like the
office of personnel management and who's
going to lead the Office of Management
and budget those two positions I think
are more important than cabinet level
positions they're like the plumbing of
the federal government and there I don't
want policy walks I want Bulldogs who
are going to not try to mediate between
me and the administrative State I think
these were some other Republican
presidents have fallen short they end up
putting people who are ambassadors for
the administrative State back to them no
these people are going to be my Bulldogs
they need to be fundamentally
anti-government
I think to succeed in shutting down the
administrative State the person who runs
the office of personnel management the
person who runs the Office of Management
and budget they need to be in their
bones
fundamentally anti-government to be able
to see that through unidirectionally and
I don't want to hear what the
administrative state has to say back in
using them as a back channel to get back
to me that's what I think what happened
to Trump happened to Reagan
happened to many other presidents with
the best of intentions these people are
going to be bulldogs they're going to go
in there intentionally break it they're
going there to break it so I think a lot
about those positions I have some ideas
they're not going to be people with
government experience that's a good
thing and then the cabinet level
appointments I have some good ideas of
who are gonna those will be people with
more government experience
then I get to vice president
there's a couple different models of the
role
one is somebody who actually could give
me a sense of
I don't say spiritual grounding but
centering right uh and there's there's a
couple people who would fit that
description for me
you know who's who's really good in this
respect that you know who would you know
he wouldn't take this job but I actually
really respect my relationship with
every time I hear her speak with Tucker
Carlson he's great deep Insight it just
happened to have seen him in Iowa a few
days ago but
deep insight into
what's really going on in the American
psyche and that's part of the psyche I
share and so I you know I think that you
could think of someone anyway like that
a sort of a
a political priest style figure right
you could then have somebody who's
actually going to be a supplement to the
Office of Management budget or OPM an
Executor so you're just bring an
additional muscle in I think that's an
appealing way to use that position
because you're going to need it's going
to require more people who are actual
muscle doers to shut down the federal
government the executive branch of it
than people who are just pontificating
about it so I think that's the second
model that I think I could use and then
the third model would be somebody who's
just a domain expert in an area where I
lack domain expertise the most and I
think that's another model that's worked
for me what would that be for you so for
me it's actually foreign policy in areas
outside of the areas of foreign policy I
have paid close to 10 I mean I'm on the
foreign policy issues that matter most
to the United States starting with China
I'm deep yeah very deep I'm not going to
be taking secondhand advice from China
to how to end the war in Ukraine to
rethinking our alliances with the UN or
NATO both of which I think about live
their purposes there I'm good but when
you think about the other areas of
foreign policy our relations with South
America parts of the Middle East you
know these are just areas where no human
being is going to have expertise in
everything but we might bring somebody
who has a similar world view but is able
to channel that to other parts of the
world so those would be the three
different models for vice president
but I want to staff out with the rest of
the apparatus looks like because then
it'll show which of those three is
really the rate limiter that I need and
I think any one of those three is
a viable choice for the type of person
that I put in a VP role uh we have from
Joshua bra the leftist cult worships at
the altar of Planned Parenthood this is
definitely something I agree with I've
been saying this for a while uh I would
not say that I'm the first person to
have come up with this observation but
to the left abortion really is kind of
their Blessed Sacrament it's the thing
that they hold in highest esteem I think
it it embodies a lot of these values of
selfishness and rather than sacrificing
one's own uh pleasure or or Comfort or
you know lack of desire to face
adversity uh one simply
throws another person into the Flames or
maybe a better way of putting this is
effectively
fails to consider the well-being of
another and particularly a person who
they actually have a strong connection
to on the basis of a parent child
relationship so they can pursue their
own self-assurance to me that's kind of
at the core of everything that leftism
values I don't think it's a coincidence
that that's the issue that they seem to
get most worked up about
yeah I get concerned about calling
things leftist and writers because that
was a malice tactic man he talked about
rightists I I just we gotta unify I know
what you mean I know what you mean but I
don't like segmenting people into groups
well so but then what about maoists and
non maoists because you're saying you
don't want to be like a mouse well Mao
was like the right is a problem and he
divided his country and to get people to
go at each other to either side so that
it was easier to manipulate them but
anyway you know I I I think there's
something deep in what you say I mean I
think that labels are confining actually
and I think that we should if I'm
getting your point your point is talk
about the content of what your actual
beliefs are don't use the labels to
describe it because then you end up in a
circular loop I mean it's that's a fair
State yeah but understanding
for sure but but I'm I'm like ref I'm
like I'm talking about something
concrete within that label and what
left-wing thought stands for and like
when we first get the term leftism it's
it's from the French Revolution and what
were they doing I mean they were
slaughtering innocent people
there's historic precedent for
understanding leftism in this way
yeah I think that it's always one of
these interesting dilemmas where human
beings we require language to
communicate right and so would you
rather take the existence of a word in
that language that's 80 precise
but otherwise can actually be confining
versus
being true to actually yes every label
use of the word leftist which I don't
talk much about Republicans and
Democrats and I don't even usually use
the word the left although on occasion I
do because it's the most precise word
available to describe it it's always
this trade-off between yes you can
always be a little bit confining and a
little less than precise when you use
that label but I understand where yeah
where Sheamus is coming from where he's
crudely getting to a basic concept and
so don't fixate on the use of the word
leftist but of the people who have made
a
a fanatical movement around Planned
Parenthood as their golden calf
it's an interesting observation to make
and then as a crude heuristic we're
going to call them leftist for the
purposes of now even though we shouldn't
let that label sink in too deep well I
mean what I would say is the Divide
there a little bit yeah no term is
perfect uh uh at least when you're
dealing with politics in the United
States where things change so quickly
and just because someone's on the right
doesn't mean they're doing good things I
understand all of that but it's it's
still a label I I believe uh applies
there Noah Sanders says the vague you're
an outsider who is independently wealthy
making one of the hurdles that
candidates have to LEAP that much easier
what advice do you have for average
Americans who want to run for public
office God bless you and the great work
you do
yes so thank you for that
you know it's something I struggle with
because
one of the main problems and I've only
seen this since I've entered this race
is
what kind of Chokehold the donor class
the mega donor class has over the
Republican Party
I'm the only candidate in this race who
certainly will be on that debate stage
who
is entirely independent of
a class that views themselves as Puppet
Masters for politicians who they view as
their puppets but then that leaves the
option of
you know
limiting the people who are actually
truly independent to being those who
have actually succeeded at a scale that
shouldn't be a requirement for entering
public service
so what advice do I have I mean I guess
I've had my advice on how to become a
successful capitalist yeah we could have
a couple hours on that but if I was to
offer simple advice in a nutshell
be contrarian
be right
it sounds simple in that it's not
complex it's hard that it's not easy
it's easy to do one of those things it's
hard to do both of them
but the advice I would give you in
politics is actually kind of the same
thing
whereas no amount of money is still
going to substitute for the power of a
message
and it has to be a message that you're
uniquely delivering that nobody else is
and so in a certain sense that's being
contrary but it has to be a message that
isn't false has to be a message that is
true
so in some ways I'd give you that
General category of advice whether it's
to succeed as a capitalist which then
puts you in a position to maybe
independently serve the country in many
ways philanthropically politically or
otherwise
but even if you're not choosing the self
money making track
I think one of the ways of having an
impact period
including as somebody who may be an
aspiring public servant is to be
contrarian
and make sure you're right while you're
doing it no point in being contrarian
and doing the wrong thing but there's
really no point in Android Public
Services we're just going to say the
same thing that everybody else is saying
even if it is the right thing because
somebody else could do it instead so
that'd be my two-part advice
if the pack is running One Way run the
other way but when you do make sure
you're running actually to the right
target exactly good way of putting it
um the letter A just the letter the
letter A has chatted in VR will you
denounce the multi-billion dollar
for-profit American family court system
that separates children from parents
yes I actually have to admit this isn't
one of the areas where I've dived deep
but any institution that separates
parents and their children and that has
cynical interests behind it fueling that
is a corrupt institution and so denounce
it yes what I need to do more homework
on is what I can actually do about it
because a lot of that is actually at the
state level
I'm running for U.S president
I think part of running for U.S
president means there are certain
problems that bad as badly as you want
to to solve them you have to because of
the 10th Amendment in this country the
way we're set up the right thing to do
is to leave it to the states to solve
that problem but in terms of calling
attention to it and the question was
denounce it yeah I'm right there with
you
Sanctuary cities was another one you
mentioned earlier that I was like how
are you going to federally knock out
California's Sanctuary City yeah so one
of the things is again that has to be
driven by the states however there you
do have the federal purse power right
these states are all receiving large
block grants from the federal government
I don't like that system but so long as
we have the system I'm going to say that
you're not going to get money as a
municipality or state if you're propping
up Sanctuary cities I think it's fair
game especially because it relates to an
issue the federal government ought to be
concerned about which is immigration at
the southern border which is a national
crisis and so any state that's using and
creating the incentive for that nation
National problem that Nationwide problem
that's a legitimate use of a practice
that I also already just don't like
block grants and using the power of the
purse with respect to states to drive
behavior I'm generally a skeptic of that
but that limited circumstance if there's
a use case for doing it on proper
Authority that would be it does that
make sense oh yeah yeah
I was just thinking of other contrary
ways to go about solving the problem as
you were speaking totally I mean I think
we might need a new we do need a new
governor in California too and I think
that'll be even much more effective at
direct Landing the sanctuary City
problem there than what I'm going to do
as president but I'll do my part do you
also think that it'll help with
immigration at the northern border I've
been so stunned to see the uh rapid
increase of illegal immigration at the
northern border through Canada it's back
to that hydraulic pump you start
squeezing in one place it shows up in
another so I've done the math on this I
think when we look at the undeployed
troops or troops that are deployed in
places they shouldn't be we absolutely
have enough to be able to seal the Swiss
cheese of a southern border and to
secure most of the vulnerable parts of
our northern border as well
and I actually think this is one of the
ways we revive
pride in our military it's one of the
things we've lost is the purpose of that
institution right fought pointless Wars
for a long time
young men and women going to die
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
of taxpayer money now 25 percent of
young people actually young people don't
want to serve the military we have a 25
recruitment deficit in the U.S military
last year
part of the way we fix that problem is
let's use our military to actually
who would have ever thought protect the
lives
of Americans hmm starting your own
American soils I think that's also one
of the ways we solve that crisis of
purpose in our military when the
military lacks purpose that's when
wokeism and gender ideology substitute
and fill the void in some ways it's the
Pentagon they blow woke smoke to deflect
accountability for their own failure of
mission over the last 25 years
fighting pointless Wars wokeness is a
great deflection tactic
just like it is for the public schools
let me say math is racist it's a great
way to deflect attention from saying
you're not actually you can't actually
teach them math right exactly no yeah if
you don't want to be involved with it
you don't want to do it if you're
failing at it call it racist
um we're gonna wrap up now this has been
an awesome conversation I want to thank
you so much for for joining us and also
just to give you an opportunity to plug
anything else you'd like to to the
audience let them know where they can
find more of your work and what they can
do to help you out yeah I mean the thing
called plug is an idea
actually the idea that
our diversity is not our strength
now we've got I'm glad I brought a
different shade of melon into this room
I have a couple different genders
there's two genders by the way we have
two genders in this room right
who cares
hey we've grown so
habituated to celebrating our diversity
and our differences
that we forgot all of the ways were
really just the same
As Americans Bound by a common Creed and
so
what's The Parting pitch I want to leave
with people it is this it is e pluribus
unum
the founding Creed of this country from
many
one
and if you share that Vision with me and
you want to see that revived in our
country in a national identity around it
then help me do it I I'm in this
volunteer to do my part
my kids will be entering High School in
January 2033 when I'm leaving office
after two terms I'm ready to do it we're
going to stop at nothing
but help me get there go to the vet the
website is vivek2024.com
it's my first name v-i-v-e-k
2024.com
and do whatever suits you sign up as a
volunteer
join the list hear more if you have some
money donate it that's great we'll take
that too for those who are able for
those who aren't help us in a different
way
but I think it's going to take each of
us to do our part I'm not going to come
from the White House on high to promise
to save us like a messiah is going to
require each of us to do our part
and if you guys do yours I promise you
I'll do mine and that's why I'm in this
so cool I'm glad you can be able to come
out tonight and join us it's been an
awesome conversation as predicted uh I'm
Hannah brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com you can follow at
timcastnews on Twitter and Instagram if
you want to follow me personally I'm uh
hankler.be on Instagram and HC brimo on
Twitter again thank you so much for
coming out oh yeah man pleasure always
and come back when Tim's on when Tim's
back oh yeah I'm back we'll do this
again this is great tell us what's up yo
dog and uh uh VR yo we didn't talk about
virtual reality and the metaverse and
what's coming in the next 15 20 years
maybe we'll talk about that next time
yeah alphabetically comes after VP next
is VR
qvr yeah I love it so we'll do that
catch you later man
yeah pleasure meeting you my friend uh I
didn't get to speak to you previously
and I was really looking forward to it
so it's nice to finally close the loop I
guess you could say Yes
um yeah it's good to see you man yeah
pleasure uh imessage.com on the internet
are you with me on Twitter I love it
guys uh yeah that was a good one Sheamus
you did a good job oh thank you thank
you well I had a an awesome guest uh my
name is Seamus Coughlin I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes where we do
animated cartoons I think you guys will
enjoy those we just got the keys
returned to us by YouTube there was a
mistake we were locked out for a couple
days but we're back in business if you
enjoy comedy if you enjoy my perspective
go check those cartoons out also if you
enjoy what I have to say you uh like me
as a podcaster I have a rumble Channel
called shamer we stream at least twice a
week we're going to be uploading uh a
lot of streams next week that'll be
premiering live if you guys want to
check that out
um and also if you want to support me
financially become a member at
freedomtunes.com and you'll get an extra
cartoon each week as well as behind the
scene content so what I want to ask you
all to do is smash the like like button
on this video share the video If you
enjoyed it and become a member at
timcocast.com timcast.com oh my gosh I
almost nevadaed it it's cast not cost
Claire timcast.com uh go over to
timcast.com and join us for the after
show which is going to be live at about
10 10. thank you we should say before
full disclosure you may be bouncing out
early I know you've got a speech
tomorrow so if you guys maybe we'll have
an opportunity to take calls early or
something I don't know technically if
you like that idea if you're still out I
can hang around for a few minutes I
really want to take a few calls all
right we'll see you at timcast.com yeah
see you there later get back those
spoons chairman